well we're starting to know what it
feels like in seattle because it is
playing out in a very public way one of
my favorite lines from the office and
one of my favorite episodes was the
dinner party
and michael and jan were engaged in this
back and forth of awkwardness and i
think at one point jim says to the
camera and i'm not gonna get this right
but it's along the lines of i think
michael and jan are playing their own
game and it's called let's see how
uncomfortable we can make our guests and
they're both winning that's kind of
what's going on with the seahawks and
russell wilson right now we are the
guests
and they have a little game apparently
of let's see how uncomfortable we can
make our fans and the media because
look chris we we can
we can
break down the various points that
russell wilson made on dan patrick's
show on tuesday and i do believe that at
some point we'll look back on that
moment as one of the major steps in
quarterbacks
in the nfl becoming like basketball
players in the nba where they understand
they've got a lot more power than they
ever exercised before i don't think any
of the details matter i think this is
like a situation where we've probably
all been there at some point or we've
been on the other end of it you know
you're dating someone and you want out
and all those things that didn't bother
you for all that time all of a sudden
bother you like you knew about it you
were fine with it going in right but now
it bothers you because you're just
looking for a reason to get out that's
what it comes down to you just want out
and i think that's where this is i think
and this this dovetails with what
brandon marshall said the other day on
fs1
that russell wilson's looking for a
classy way to get out he just wants out
and the next step in this came yesterday
when dan patrick said he's hearing that
the seahawks management isn't happy with
what russell wilson said on dan's show
so
is it sustainable dan doesn't seem to
think it is is russell wilson trying to
push this to the point where the only
option for the seahawks is to trade him
it's starting to feel like that's what
russell wilson's trying to set up chris
well
i agree like here's the first thing i'm
going to ask you and i don't even know
the answer to this i actually just
texted you so maybe you're reading it
right now because i wasn't sure i want
to know was russell wilson on there to
sell anything on tuesday was he selling
a subject like was he selling anything
oakley glasses i know he does all that
stuff i'm just curious because then i
would find it curious that he's on the
dan patrick show anyways on the tuesday
after the super bowl and doing that to
me if you just connect those type of
dots and mike i mean i think we think
alike and we know how the business works
like
i i don't know i just find it curious i
find the whole conversation curious of
course we talked about brandon marshall
he's got to have some inside knowledge
he was there in seattle you know he like
you talked about yesterday he
interviewed dk metcalf last week so
there's got to be something there
and
i
those comments are
they're strong i mean they're they're
real strong i understand the seattle
seahawks being a little disappointed i
mean he kind of
attacked the franchise in a very kind of
somewhat of a classy way okay a little
bit there
and and really made it basically say
like i'm i'm not happy i get hit too
much the offense isn't good enough and i
want to be involved in some of the
personnel stuff and mike as i sat
yesterday and you know watch some of
these clips more and read into it and do
all that talk to a few people
i'm with you mike i think he wants out
i think he wants out there's no i i
really get that sense just the more you
kind of wrap your head around it too and
i just wonder too if the last like nail
in the coffin
was shane waldron being hired from the
rams he's probably going what i don't
want to run that offense what run the
ball speed sweep
run the ball speed sweep play action
pass screen something he's probably
looking at he's probably going no
i don't want to do that i'm russell
wilson i'd love to play an offense like
josh allen or deshawn watson or patrick
mahomes where i can move around and make
plays and have fun and do all that stuff
i i i mike i think you're on to
something i'm i'm kind of with you on
this one and i didn't think i'd be
saying that you know yesterday morning
he had said all the right things about
shane waldron and there was a report
that he was lobbying for shane waldron
and and he said good things about
waldron when he was on with dan patrick
the other day i just think that
that it doesn't matter who the offensive
coordinator was i think the damage
was already done and it's been a long
time coming yeah and i i think that at
some point during the 2020 season that's
when russell wilson crossed that bridge
where
i i've just got to get out i i'm ready
to move on and you know he's getting
some blowback locally i do a thing on
kjr every wednesday night and i ask the
hosts
what you know what's the reaction there
and some of the former players have been
on radio like walter jones saying this
is wrong this is a bad look he shouldn't
be criticizing his teammates and that
kind of gets lost in this because we're
focused on what's going on with russ
well it was he is it was
very out of character across often he
gets hits that that that's a shot at the
offensive lineman all of them that have
protected him it was kind of a shot at
everybody i mean it was a shot i don't
know there's no other way to say it i
mean it was a shot across the bow it
wasn't even across the bow it was
directly into it it was like i'm not
real happy
i'm not i mean he he kind of said it you
know he kind of was trying to tiptoe
around it
and dan you know how to ask the question
three times right and then he finally
answered it and
yes i i think he just kind of started to
let his emotions out but there's really
no avenue of the organization he kind of
didn't hit would go
i'm not loving it there's no doubt about
it and you know again the other thing
i'll say too is like you you just hit on
a point that i was gonna bring up
anyways
at some point in the 2020 season right
he realized it
i can't help but to think
he carries the team early on in the year
he is the team early on in the year
then they go through a little losing
streak and i'm just trying to get this
exactly at the right spot where
what was it the rams game and maybe the
bills game i think it was those two
games he threw an interception oh he
threw two interceptions
and it became
we can't play this way
we got to go back to running the
football and doing that crap and being
really basic and all that i mean that's
it literally switched to that instantly
the guy had a a one average game and
they were like that's it we can't do
this anymore we gotta change and i'm
sure that would be a point if i was a
quarterback where i'd be going
wow really i mean i'm the mvp of
football i have two average weeks and
now we're not going to play that's
that's all the chances i get i mean and
and i would understand him being
frustrated about that too
and you know it's almost like it's a
pete carroll versus russell wilson thing
it's like a clash of cultures
yeah and and who's gonna win and
ordinarily wouldn't you say
wouldn't you say that the the franchise
quarterback who's 32 years old who has
made it clear he wants to play until
he's 45 so he's got 13 more years left
pete carroll's pushing 70.
now pete carroll has also said
he's you know he hasn't put an
expiration date on his career either i
remember when robert kraft at the league
meetings a few years ago told me that
that he wants bill belichick to coach
into his 80s and i ran that by carol
that same day and carol said why stop
there so he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy who's going to walk away but you
know ownership in all of this it's been
paul allen's sister that's been running
the team
since paul allen died a couple of years
ago
and you know with most teams you know
exactly
who it is that's going to make this call
yeah i don't know who in seattle is
going to make this call and i don't know
nearly enough about the current owner of
the team to have any understanding about
who she's going to defer to and who
she's going to side with and there's a
hell of a decision that someone's going
to have to make here you know i think we
know though i mean i do i mean i mean
pete carroll and john schneider are
running the organization right i mean i
don't there's nothing that
there's like you said you know there
there's nothing that makes us believe
that that's not it right i mean at least
that i know of maybe there's more but
but my point is you still have an owner
yeah you still have a number this isn't
the green bay packers still got someone
who owns the team and jody allen who has
been running the franchise since paul
allen passed right she can she can
ultimately say to them
make it happen he wants out let's do a
trade let's go or or tell him
too bad
or tell him too bad
he's he's under contract with us i don't
care if he wants out he can he can say
whatever he wants he's under contract
with us for three more years and that's
the way it's going to be so uh there's
just it's a weird dynamic now because
the mess has been made the question is
how do they go about cleaning it up the
battle lines are drawn the seahawks
aren't happy with him he's not happy
with them where does it go from here he
hasn't asked to be traded like deshaun
watson but he's taken all this dirty
laundry and he's dropped it in front of
us to see and inspect and and pick
through and understand what's really
going on yeah and what's going on is he
wants out yeah i mean
i i think more more things point to that
than
than anything else i i i don't have any
doubt about that you're right i mean and
and i just
it's it's curious it really is i mean
it's crazy
i but i just feel like with russell
wilson as smart as he is you know he
pays attention to football
everything like that
it seems like this was tactical it just
seems that way to a degree
and
i don't know what seattle's gonna do
about this situation but they're in a
tough spot now certainly and i don't
know they're gonna have to talk and
figure it out
things have escalated very quickly it's
like desean like you said about desean
watson like he might never come out and
say i want to be traded right because
once you say that publicly whatever
it gets used against you i think he's
going to play both
sides a little bit even he did in the
interview he still talked about seattle
loves playing there loves the fans all
that so he's protecting himself but he's
also letting it be known
that
he's not happy with the way they play
football there's no doubt somebody asked
me a very important question yesterday
did he say go hawks
at the end of the interview but you know
what i've spoken to him several times on
the phone after games and that's a
different setting than
than the normal interview but a few
times i've spoken to him in the past
couple of years he has not said go hawks
at the end so i i but that's different
than the press conference setting the
formal interview setting i don't think
he said go hawks when he was sitting
with us last year at the super bowl
either though and that's when we first
started to see
the cracks when we started to see that
let rust cook desire
begin to come out and remember
but remember when they first embraced
the whole let rust cook thing and it was
working
i was told that they did what they had
to do because if you don't let russ cook
he's going to go find himself a
different kitchen and the other line was
you're going to be cooking him a
farewell cake so
they let him cook for a while and then
they took it away to get to your point
they took it away quickly
and
that may have been the moment where he
said all right time for a new kitchen
yeah it just and then and then they're
just going it's just it's too hard it's
it's life is made too hard on them too
much
the offense is basic it's too reliant on
him making plays just with his pure
ability you know and here's the other
thing because you brought up last year
oh radio road down there in miami we
brought this up then or maybe it was the
year before maybe i'm off by that was
last year it was miami
like we brought up though we brought up
the off-season before
when he went on jimmy fallon and it
seemed like there was a question planted
of hey ask me about my contract
situation like that's what it seemed
like we i kind of had fun with him and
asked him about that and he did a great
job of kind of answering it the way he
wanted to
that's where i go back to the dan
patrick thing yesterday and just go
why where where did that or where did
that interview request go down that's
where i'd love to know and if he wasn't
selling anything too that means
then he was trying to sell this point
and and he wanted to get this out there
and let it be known right now
he was named the walter payton man of
the year so i don't think he was on
dan's show last week and this is kind of
spill over from the super bowl thing
it's like hey we didn't get you on last
week let's go ahead and try to do it
this week but but hey at the end of the
day
he's two days removed from sitting at
the super bowl yes with his wife on one
side the commissioner on the other and
dan joked with him at one point about
how miserable he looked and he said yeah
i am i don't want to be watching these
guys play i want to be playing in that
game here he is six years after it was
brady versus wilson he's got to sit and
watch brady versus mahomes
so i can understand why he's frustrated
and and again this is all part of
what what is a dramatic shift
in the way that quarterbacks behave
not the way they think but the way they
behave there had been a fear there had
been
a an aversion to saying anything that
could get the fan base or the media
stirred up against them and russell
wilson was resented by teammates early
in his career because he was viewed as a
company man right and my how it has
changed because now
he is causing
hey uh chaos
and wreaking havoc for the seattle
seahawks with these things that he said
in a very professional way
that that's what's amazing about it you
know it reminds me of the comments from
patrick mahomes right after the super
bowl and as i said i think wilson and
mahomes are two guys who can pull it off
they can say anything they've got a
natural charisma that allows them to use
whatever words they want and it doesn't
strike us
as oh my god i can't believe he's saying
that and i think when the more i watch
the things that wilson said and listen
to his words
it really isn't anything that seems out
of line or over the top but the message
is unlike anything that we
have heard quarterbacks speak about
publicly and candidly no but i i think
we're going to see this more and more in
football all together
you know you you said it we've talked
about it it's the nba aspect to a degree
antonio brown
showed everybody you can force your way
out of town when you're a superstar and
you tell them i'm gonna act a fool and
all of a sudden then they go okay we
gotta get you out of here you do have
that option and i think
really what's going to continue to
happen
more than anything because
the talk is always quarterback
quarterback quarterback who have you win
do you win how many super bowls do you
have some of these quarterbacks are
going to go i got to start making my own
luck you know i didn't get drafted by a
team that could help me and set me up
and build the team and give me what i
want so if i'm going to be judged
against these other guys who you know
we're fortunate to get what they want i
think you're going to start to see
quarterbacks go damn i'm going to put
myself to give myself an opportunity to
and no matter what it is and they're
going to worry about their legacy their
brand and everything like that and i
think that's the the road we're going
down right now especially at the
quarterback position because that's all
it's about it's all guys are being
judged by
and this is a unique kind of a bookend
for tom brady because he was criticized
for never pushing to get every last
dollar that he deserved and that helped
keep the quarterback market down because
if you've got one guy who's saying i
want x
that sets the ceiling and the others
fall in behind at the lower the ceiling
the harder it is to get paid so that
hurt other quarterbacks and i remember
when kirk cousins was making the
argument as he was moving toward free
agency in washington he felt like it was
his obligation to make as much as
possible to help other quarterbacks
that's a hell of a way to justify i'm
gonna go grab every dollar i can but now
what tom brady did this year
that has emboldened quarterbacks in a
different way this isn't about money now
this is about i want to go to the place
where i think i'm going to win
and i'm inspired by what tom brady did
and i'm sick of this that old
you that old fart is still winning super
bowls i'm 32. i'm in my prime right yeah
he's going i'm better than him i wanna
right i'm better than tom brady right
why don't i go to tampa where's my tampa
which team is my equivalent of tampa and
how can i get there and i can't fault
russell wilson for feeling that oh i
can't either it's the way these guys are
being judged right now it and it's not
it's not fair to some of them so that's
where i get it you know it is it's the
lebron james factor oh you're not
michael jordan you're not michael jordan
you're not michael jordan well okay look
at this damn team in cleveland this
first where's scotty pippen yeah right
his first and we can't even name guys on
his team he was going to the nba finals
with back in 2007-8 i can't even
remember i'm a huge basketball fan
that's how average they were so he went
i got to make my own luck and that's
what i think we're going to continue to
see hey marty schottenheimer yesterday
is a great example too of how we're
being judged a little bit the guy was
one of the all-time winners at the
position his obituary in the washington
post started off with his playoff losses
didn't even talk about all the great
things it started off with
play off failure like that that's where
it started so
that's the world we're in right now and
i think guys like russell wilson and
aaron rodgers and deshawn watson
are very aware of it and that's why
you know to what you're saying mike
they're gonna start making their own
moves their own destiny their own luck
shireen williams made an excellent point
yesterday on pftpm and i want to dust it
off and i want to i want to run this by
you cool she she
she said
that right now in the nfl there are not
many
situations where
the quarterback is 100 committed to the
team
and the team is 100 committed to the
quarterback and she's right here's my
list yeah based upon our conversation
from last night and i thought about it
yeah cool obviously the chiefs obviously
the chiefs in the bucks yeah chiefs in
the box even though tom brady's 43
they're cook completely
so chiefs bucks bills josh allen
obviously yeah ravens lamar jackson
obviously bengals joe burrow even with
that injury they they saw enough yeah
they're all in with joe burrow
chargers and justin herbert all in
that's that's six kyla murray
tyler murray is are they are they all in
for multiple years let's say yeah okay
sure shireen equivocated a little bit
because she doesn't like him because he
transferred away from texas
just because of that just because of
that that's how loyal she is to the
aggies um the the other one that that we
were kind of on the fence about and this
is another a m guy shannon hill who's
ryan tanner ryan tano and the titans i
would say so for two years more i think
they're pretty damn committed on both
sides i i think okay what about aaron
rodgers you can't say it for aaron
rodgers if you go two years now can you
say that they're really committed for
two more years
not a hundred percent yeah it doesn't no
you're right i i cannot i cannot and i
don't know how he feels about that
either but you know obviously we know
he's not like thrilled with the
organization and there's got to be
something on his radar always looking
but i think really
you pretty much hit it right there maybe
the rams are stoppers percent of the
league all right maybe raiders maybe
like maybe yeah it's close but just
because of the current circumstances
what they traded to get him i would
think he's got two years for sure
so but but it's not really the point of
what we're talking about franchise guys
who are at a spot and they really
committed that right now and i think you
hit and this is more this is more
stafford stafford is the next chapter i
mean yeah stafford is the result of what
happens when you're not committed yeah
right i'm talking about right existence
from last year they're going to carry
into this year and one more year right
clear connection with two years left
chris i think it's 25 of the league yeah
isn't that amazing it's amazing eight
teams are fully committed for two more
years and the quarterback is fully
committed and all in for two more years
that's it it's amazing and again mike i
think it's going to go down something
we've had a lot of discussions about it
the last year that teams are going to
start to realize that yeah there's six
or seven that are really special and we
don't let them leave town the rest huh
we can win with yeah it might not be
apples to apples as each guy but there's
enough talented guys in the league right
now to go oh okay i could get him and
play this way and win oh i can get that
guy and we'd have to play this way and
win and i think it's
i think it's
and honestly i'm i'm actually rooting
for it i i'm hoping it's going to
devalue the position a little bit you
know i i am i'm it's not about like i
just think more of the wealth needs to
be spread around and we don't need to
have average quarterbacks making 40
million dollars a year
you know that that's an amazing
unintended consequence of this effort by
quarterbacks to flex their muscles the
end result is and and look we've been
saying it it needs to evolve into a
system of tears
the top tier guys make a certain amount
of money the middle tier guys make a
certain amount and this idea and i think
one of the reasons why it happened and
and and the list went andrew luck derek
carr
jimmy garoppolo kirk cousins matt ryan
it was like one testing the other
because the market at the position was
held down for several years there was a
stretch there from 2013
with the joe flacco contract and aaron
rodgers got something in that ballpark
too but there was a period of time four
or five years where
no one was really busting that curve so
that was part of the correction but now
i think we're at a point where
you've got your five guys who are
clearly above and beyond the others
you've got
ten guys after that and then you've got
everybody else yeah but
uh yeah look it's changing in a lot of
ways
and i know that there's some old school
football types that don't like it well
you don't have to like it but you better
get ready for it and you better adapt
your way of thinking to it because
that's where the game is going and uh
quarterbacks are are starting to realize
that they've got power and with russell
wilson's comments from the other day
with deshaun watson's trade demand and
everything else that's going on all
sparked by tom brady packing up and
leaving new england last year these
quarterbacks are ready to think about
what else is out
there hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports